this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman TV
advertising news we don't do a lot of
this but I thought this was worth
talking about Burger King is ditching
their slogan after 40 years they're
saying goodbye to their slogan so
they're no longer gonna be like weird
number two that was never their slogan
the slogan was have it your way that's
right
that was their promise you could go in
and special orders would not upset them
that's all the pickles all the lettuce
special orders don't upset as I don't
know the rest of the works all we ask is
that you let us have it your way
have it your way where did you grow up
Russian spy anyway they've changed the
slogan from have it your way to a new
slogan rolled out this week be your way
what does they even [ __ ] mean it
sounds very yoga to me have it your way
I understand it means I can get the
burger any way I want it be your way
means are they giving me permission to
be myself
well I don't take the orders from the
Burger King I don't live in burger land
he's not my king you don't acknowledge
that throne I don't have it your way was
a slogan that inferred that if you come
in you can have it any way you want
right but be your way if you're like hey
man I want to have it my way they're
like well we don't promise that anymore
all we promises you can be your way you
could just be just stand there and be
and eat our burgers the way we make them
they said the problem was this is a
quote from the corporate office the
problem is that people don't see
themselves as living the Burger King
lifestyle if there is a Burger King
lifestyle if I found myself living that
lifestyle I'd cut my wrists with an
onion ring I would I would take myself
out if I was living the Burger King
lifestyle whatever that [ __ ] is I
don't want to be it they'd find you
hanging from the rafters of the BK
lounge that's right
I just want to be
and go away don't make me live your
lifestyle some of the rejected slogans
they didn't go with we're slightly
better than Wendy's that's it they get
maximum tastes the minimum wage that
didn't make it in Burger King when your
arteries are just too damn clean also
didn't make the cut and eat up fat ass
that also didn't get in as well Oh
that'd be amazing I would go eat there
if they were that honest eat up fat ass
like I will King not to be outdone
putting it under my arms for later keeps
it warm again
not to be outdone McDonald's is also
unleashed a new advertising campaign for
their happy meals kids aren't eating
enough happy meals apparently so they've
got a brand new character to introduce
to the little kids called happy let's
meet happy shall we the meal st do i eat
me response has been mixed to say the
best reviews have been everything from
creepy all the way to terrifying
apparently this character has been very
popular in france since 2009 mmm
yeah whether a bunch of cowards over
there what do they know I'm kidding -
have any French here now you do too
afraid to say you're here aren't you
welcome
[Music]
you
[Music]